hello seas world I'd like to start by
thanking everyone who sent me a message
asking for my thoughts on the marina
joys [ __ ] that's been going on over the
last month I went ahead and watched her
videos and I would definitely agree that
there's some creepy undertones there if
you don't know marina Joyce is a British
vlogger who became the center of a
hashtag save marina Joyce when she
started act strangely in her videos and
people began to notice things like
bruises people controlling her and
apparent cries for help and encoded
messages on her channel so I decided why
not get marina herself on the line to
discuss them the weird stuff that I've
noticed in her videos how you doing
today marina that's wonderful to hear
marina it sounds like we might be having
a little bit of connection issues here
but I know there are a lot of people out
there who are genuinely worried about
you right now and I'm not personally of
the belief that you're part of like a
hostage situation or anything but I do
see some questionable things going on in
your videos all right well I'll tell you
what I've got a big list of strange
things that I took note of while
watching your channel can we just kind
of go through and get your side of the
story on some of these big ones so you
can finally put some of these questions
behind you so it seems like all of the
controversy began on your video how to
lose weight a lot of people have been
theorizing that your quote-unquote
captors told you to make this video as a
reaction to the comments that you're
getting thinner so what's your official
statement on that
whoa whoa hold up for one sec so when
you say positive energy you just mean
you feel a healthy or are you talking
about like some kind of spiritual energy
take all the time you need
Maryna
no worries is everything okay hey marina
like I said earlier I think some of the
rumors flying around about you right now
are pretty crazy but if there is I don't
know something going on right now well
you should just know that it's not too
late to come forward and be direct about
it okay I'll take your word for it but
just keep that in mind
so I think we left off on the lose
weight video it looks like you have some
heavy bruising on your knuckles is there
an explanation for that all right I
guess that makes sense but what about
the things that girls do that guys hate
video your knees are covered in bruises
and then in one of the skits we see your
boyfriend grab your arm in a spot where
bruises appear in a later video okay I
heard you mentioned something like that
in the interview that you did with
Philip DeFranco I believe but I mean I
assume we're just talking about one fall
that you had and some of these bruises
do look pretty bad maybe this is just
the meteor and me talking but I thought
you said that you were much healthier as
a vegan and actually I wrote down this
quote from one of your videos that I
found kind of odd it says being vegan is
the healthiest time that my skin has
ever been and that
have ever been but if you're getting
bruises so easily from being a vegan it
just seems to be like a contradiction so
what's the point of continuing fair
enough
let's jump to your next video curling
with a straightener there's a time-lapse
eggman twith music over it where I can
see you talking to someone who is that
viously you have a very close
relationship with your mother and I
think that what has people concerned
with this video and I'm not trying to be
accusatory here is that you look very
uncomfortable whenever you're looking
and talking off camera and then the
other thing is that there's no camera
movement anywhere in the video so why
would you even need help making it
marina you're cutting out can you hear
me Marina marina can you hear me now no
worry it's just a couple more questions
on that video
in the background and this is something
that I've seen in a lot of your recent
videos you can see these dinner plates
which have given people the idea that
you're locked up in a room and you're
being given these meals every day or
something again I don't subscribe to the
kidnapper theory I think it's total crap
but what can you tell us about that at
the end of the video you say I wish to
speak with you in the comments but then
you don't reply to any of the comments
what is that about
but but what I'm asking is why would you
specifically say I wish to speak with
you if you know for a fact that you
won't have time to reply to the comments
is this a cry for help of sorts okay
like I said I believe you but how do you
explain what you said in dyeing my hair
pink where you asked the viewers for
tips on healing yourself and tell
everyone that you're really good at
dealing with pain Maryna everything okay
all right well I know you're short on
time so what do you say we skip to the
big one date outfit ideas there is so
much questionable stuff going on in this
video
people off-camera seem to be telling you
what to do weird behavior someone
watching you through the window and then
something keeps scaring your cat there's
bruises and then there's this subliminal
frame of you holding your head where do
we even begin with this what's that okay
marina what's going on over there marina
can you hear me Marina marina what's
happening marina
you